mon chien sébastien est la question 1
par exemple on dit pour le handicap
vous prenez la place de handicap et
prenait vivais ma vie est ce que vous
avez envie
est ce que vous auriez aimé être noah
être arabe dans la société française
d'aujourd'hui
je me suis jamais d'avoir posé la
question parce que vous aimez la
question des gens à travers la couleur
de leur peau et moi qui vivent je vous
réponds de christine en étant brun au
teint mat barbu et méchant et mac contre
le front national
les mecs là là c'est en cash par les
peaux kebab a annoncé que je veux dire
c'est que évidemment moi je ne réalise
pas les rami ou demain oui est ce que ça
vient de passer une journée dans la peau
de noix différents joueurs pour leur
hymne
alors moi on peut continuer vous dire
une femme noire on voit au collectif
avec heures on est comme une femme que
c'est plus difficile et je continuais
femme séduit vous pouvez rajouter tout
qui recrée de la difficulté dans le
parcours en une les mois je suis venu en
streaming
je le dénonce je ne nie pas qu'il ya des
discriminations et disent que je
considère que vous avez privatiser la
lutte contre le racisme à des fins
politiques non non on se bat pour
l'égalité on monsieur est allusif alors
karim zéribi le dit en quoi ça vous
dérange temps de considérer qu'il ya un
racisme anti blanc ça me dérange réalité
à ce que monde le reconnaisse le journal
le monde déficit avec armin les a coupés
lorsqu'il ya des manifestations anti cpe
le journal le monde titre manifestation
anti blanc il ya des festivals et on
interdit aux blancs dans notre pays on
hidalgo la dénoncer ce sont des réalités
il y à un racisme et ouvrez les yeux
devant timothy derijck et surtout
accepter juste de le traiter de la même
planète terminé terminée vikash
apprendre à jimmy kébé arrêté dire ça
n'existe analystes
droit de le dire maj argumenté pas
rejeté sa jeudi la sécu c'est que carrie
c'est ma vie vous qui pointe et toute la
journée dans ce pays la faute des
musulmans la faute des immigrés toute la
journée vous faites ça vous voulez venir
nous expliquer comment les combattre le
racisme et le média me mohamed qui veut
pas laisser partir d'un exemple tout
simple sur les plateaux télé voyez
beaucoup de noirs et d'arabes sans le
blesser un peu différents cantons moi
mais parce que l'euro c'est le bled
c'est un problème avec moi j'ai sauvé ma
tach j'entends barbu l'harmattan le bled
les mecs j'ai raison si vous ne m'aimez
pas d'en dégoûter pas les
téléspectateurs
merci oui ce que vous pouvez me dire où
se passe où sont passés les journalistes
étudiants noirs arabes
une fois qu'ils passent de séries télé
ou est ce qu'ils sont expliquez moi
lorsque alors c'est difficile de dire ça
mais lorsque les blancs parce que c'est
pas une insulte dire les blancs comme
les noirs s'entraide entre eux et
marchands réseau c'est du piston lorsque
les noirs ou les arabes cherchent à
s'entre aider à créer des liens on
appelle ça le communautarisme et là tout
de suite c'est le danger chez un peu
d'amour vrai que j'aimerais juste que le
grand lecteur naulleau me disent on l'a
pas mis à jour son compte twitter le
lait que leur naulleau est ce qu'un jour
pour me fait de sa couleur c'est pas une
insulte de son nom de ses origines a été
discriminée dans la vie de tous les
jours pour accéder à une fonction est ce
qu'un seul jour cet art ibérique moi
j'ai dit tout à l'heure qui avait un
communautarisme island donc non il ya
même un communautariste pour être précis
et même un communautarisme des élites et
un système de retraite des élites qui
pour moi est exactement le même que
n'importe quel autre système dont je ne
fais pas de différence je dis simplement
qu'il y à des coins dans la république
française où il ne fait pas bon être
blanc où on est traité de sale français
et aussi que les et laurence hallier
jeudi je dis qu'à descoings dans la
république sociale minars fesf avant
l'épreuve juifs et oui c'est les mêmes
et il arrive trop tôt
on se fait traiter de sale français
juifs non mais autant l'hiver sortir des
conneries pareilles c'est pas mon bateau
mais si vous pouvez l'appeler niveau
très bas du déni j'ai des rares
appareils commandés l'immédiat
gilles icher crédit individuel il ya des
coins entier de la république où il n'y
a plus rien des noirs qui domine les
blancs dans la france quelque part dans
un village lui j'étais juif ou et
enchaîne un coin allez pouvoir quelque
part on a beaucoup dit qu'elle est
malgré les blancs real madrid
vous entendez villa mais oui mais
fonctionne oui ou non la synagogue
[Rires]
à la menthe attentat raté ce que je fais
du c4 à quel qu'en soit le coût ttc
je suis pas jean-luc mélenchon moi je
peux le dire
alors non je vous dis m me pose la
question pourquoi parce que je viens des
lilas week aux téléspectateurs voilà
dans 93 et voilà donc elle me demande si
la synagogue des lilas marche c'est vrai
qu'on a fait un petit business pendant
quelques années maintenant de là à dire
qu'on a prospéré
non non je veux dire non voilà les noms
je me mets à la place des gens qui
écoutent qui subissent ce racisme blanc
et qui maintenant est ce moi subir la
double peine c'est à dire le déni c'est
ce que vous vivez n'existe pas ce que
vous pensez vous ne devez pas le penser
et ce que vous devriez dire à ce sujet
vous ne devez pas le dire moi je me mets
à leur place il doit être enragé et
qu'est ce qu'ils font eh ben ils vont
chez monsieur chez nous mais ils ont
déjà sorti suis fait attaquer que par
des gens d'extrême droite s'appelle
ouvrant ces deux chiche ong pacoima
tribune et j'aurais caire 11 millions de
racheter 11 millions d'électeurs qui ont
annoncé réunion détient parti raciste
tout ce que je veux dire quelque chose
vous mais pas vous décrire la réalité de
l'économie comme a dit mais je terminais
mon beau mais c'est à côté des criminels
permettez je vais terminer ma vraie
voulait créer monsieur je terminais mon
propos il a intérêt de votre problème
c'est que vous êtes dans des dénis
multiples vous êtes dans le déni du
racisme anti blanc j'ai décidé que je
termine on fera comme amélie fédération
veut dire quelque chose monsieur jamais
je ne pourrais vous convaincre du
contraire
à moins que je ne me peigne en autre
chose que la couleur blanche forêt je me
paye peut-être en noir blanc jaune pour
vous faire comprendre que je ne suis pas
raciste si vous connaissez un rapport à
l'hymne national et raciste je défends
martyrs et de rassemblement national où
les franciliens ils ont changé les noms
je serai là c'est un peu une opinion
religieuse quelle que soit leur origine
je dépends et ses cinq frères et la
france et que nous avons du racisme
monsieur effectivement on a compris que
si c'est avec vous on pourrait pas
concourir aux élections
monsieur nous nous défendons tous les
français non nous raconte réplique
républicains y compris celui là quand on
ira je me défende il pratique la laïcité
l'égalité entre hommes et femmes
je ne suis pas sûr que dans les gens que
vous avez par ailleurs son discours ces
gens-là défendent exactement ça ces
batraciens auparavant dans son discours
et que deux choses il veut défendre les
français et rentrer en boîte de nuit
c'est tout ce que vous pouvez m'aider au
moins sur l'un de deux points entre
homos de niche ça fait très longtemps
allez merci parce que qui veut réagir à
quatre on n'a pas trop entendu
ben non mais en fait le problème qui se
pose c'est que même si c'est le cas
d'une toute petite minorité
même si je sais pas il n'y a que cinq
six personnes de couleur blanche qui ont
un jour reçu des remarques à caractère
raciste ou discriminante
elle existe on peut pas absolument être
dans le négationnisme d'une souffrance
qui a été exprimée c'est pas c'est pas
la maladresse de pierre ménès qui
symbole qui symbolise ça il faut qu'on
arrête maladresse de pierre ménès
d'excusés moi dire que son fils était
sur le banc de touche
parce qu'elles ont elles mêmes il joue
il ya vécu des noix réservé un terrain
sis juste informé mal
lui même a commencé son propos déjà bon
monfils il est nul au futile a dit
pierse a il admis